before we
actually get into it i i've been asking
a lot of people the same two opening
questions
in all the interviews i've been doing so
we'll start with that for each of you
uh what movie have you seen the most
movie i've seen the most
is um probably uh
it's uh i swiped shut
uh and uh frozen too
oh my god that's an interesting too
well the two is not because of my kid
just not but the other one i just i
don't know i just
if it's ever on anywhere or if i ever
like see it i just kind of
compulsively have to click on it and i
just enjoy it
there's a few that are up there and i
just don't know exactly which is which
so i'll be perfectly honest
i'll name a few i would say that the
elephant man
uh the harder they come
money ball the natural and the sting
a few of those might be on my list too
um what tv
series mona would you love to guest
direct
and casey what tv series would you love
to guest star on
pride and prejudice with jennifer ely
that one the
jennifer ely bbc version from like the
is it the 90s
or 80s yeah
um i'd like to be in what we do in the
shadows
i just don't know if i could pull it off
well you never know if you try uh i'm
confident in your ability i think
you you're what we call a good actor
well those guys are really funny man
they are really good
all of them so um but yeah
um so a lot of people who do not know
about like the filmmaking aspect and the
screenplay and how it all came together
might not realize the connection of this
material with the assassination of jesse
james
um can you sort of talk about how ron
and sort of ron got involved and how you
got involved
casey because you're also a producer on
this ron wrote the novel of
assassination of jesse james by the
coward robert ford andrew dominic
adapted that one but ron is also a
screenwriter uh
and has written so many great novels
that he's um
obviously you know can can write
i i wanted to know if he was other stuff
that he wanted to do
and he went and found a couple short
stories by a friend of his jim shepherd
who's also a teacher in a
pal bronze and and i think he's written
maybe a screenplay
before this himself so
we decided on jim's story and then he
ron and jim shepard
wrote the screenplay together um and
for many years because they were
teaching as well and you know had
families and
weren't being paid and so they're doing
it on the side and i think that's why it
has such a
it's so so precise and it's so it
because it's just been
you know many dozens of drafts over ye
over the years and so they really boiled
it down to
um the best version of itself and then
mona came on
and uh refined it even more and sort of
made it
made it her own um vision mona i want to
talk about one of the things that i
found fascinating about this
is that you didn't use any sound stages
you didn't go for any like fake you know
for
lighting you wanted to use all natural
stuff i thought the filmmaking in this
was so well done
and can you sort of talk about the
actual filmmaking and what you wanted to
do with the material
thank you so much yeah i know we built
everything which is really
uh exciting to do because then you can
you know you can build if i were to
shoot in
it's a little bit like shooting on a
soundstage right because i can make the
houses large enough to accommodate the
camera and the roof tall enough to hang
the lights and and to
to to you know to create the images i
want to do
so um i think that when i read the
screenplay um
i wanted it to be really organic
natural and sensual and and therefore i
thought okay i want
nature to to really you i want you to
be able to open up the windows and the
doors and and feel you know spring come
in
and see you know the chickens outside
and like have that kind of
quality to it and have shots that take
you from inside to outside and
just feel these these um characters
connection to
to the farm and the farm life around
them and and that felt really
important in terms of understanding
um uh the stakes and how how high the
stakes are when you when you
uh when you were your whole life depends
on
uh you know as we've case now talked
about before but you know if
your animals are okay uh if there's um
drought or if there's too much rain or
you know all these things do constantly
you walk you wake up in the morning and
you go outside and you look up and you
see what's the weather going to be like
and that can really determine the rest
of
your year or season so that was a lot of
the reasons that i wanted to do that and
then
i just love shooting on celluloid i
think it's so beautiful
and um exciting it's something about
that
you know catching catching a little the
light
the magic of that and how the blacks are
so
really true and deep and the natural
color of the stock casey as a producer
how much are you producing on set and
how much are you sort of setting it up
prior to stepping on set and then
becoming like the actor if you will
most of the producing happened in the
years sort of leading up to the
you know 20 days that we're actually
standing there uh shooting
at that point i become just an actor you
know
mostly um there were some decisions at
the beginning that i sort of felt like
you know once we started you know moana
was really
wanted to film as she said and i was
sort of as as the producer but also as
an actor thinking like
oh god maybe maybe that's too too
expensive or too much for a hassle or
you know not it's going to slow
everything down those kinds of things um
but then you know i remembered that
really like
a sort of philosophy that i've tried to
keep from for
over the years which is that the mo you
know you have to sort of play for the
coach when you're
making a movie and and and that's how
the team's gonna win
uh so you s for you know you you go
along with this or master vision and
and that's the directors and so uh
you know i pretty quickly just fell into
you know being a being an actor and just
being
trying to be a support on set mona did
you choose to
uh film certain things at the beginning
of the shoot or at the end of the shoot
how did you look at
you know the schedule and decide with
the performances you wanted to bring out
of certain people do you know what i
mean
yeah i mean i i wish that i could do
that more
and to a certain extent that plays into
how you schedule your days
but when you only have um when you have
a really tight schedule and you have a
long screenplay with a lot of text it
it also becomes a lot mostly also about
you know i have um i i have a certain
amount of
of scenes that need uh
a dusk and a certain amount of scenes
that need dawn or
or or even or evening or day and it just
you know you kind of have to break it
down that way
and luckily um i have
such good actors working with me that i
have that i
you know trust that they as long as i
could help sort of not get them in terms
of where we were in the story
um uh they would they would be fine
even though i couldn't you know but you
try you really try to be
i you know to to especially for
katherine waterson who plays abigail and
who has
you know who's never who's in every
scene and has super
incredibly challenging um scenes that
she has to do one right after another
i tried to to help her out but no it's
it's it's hard to have
you know that kind of luxury on a 24 a
day shoot
on that note i have to stop i'm just
going to say congrats sincerely to both
of you i thought this film was so well
done
um have a fantastic day good luck with
the speed dating
thanks thanks man